[Music]
ah the internet there is no shortage of
controversial opinions out on the
internet of course you can always find
great analysis and awesome thoughts and
wrap-ups of things everywhere but tucked
into the corners and in the comment
section there's always just a couple
extra little controversial fun
statements people are willing to throw
out into the world the hot take now I
love Hot takes because they are
guaranteed to ruffle some feathers and
get people worked up but also by
definition there's got to be just some
some element of truth to it just just a
little hint of Truth so today I've
gathered some of the hottest takes for
you guys from around the tech world and
we're going to actually see if they are
good takes or not also shout out again
to Jimmy highy roller for the initial
concept and the inspiration for this
series if you haven't already seen his
NBA hot takes they're hilarious they're
incredible I'll leave a link below go
watch them and also I'll leave a link to
the Chevron sweater below because it's
the perfect time of year to get one of
these things okay let's jump in to the
hot takes so here's our first one
cybertruck Tesla cybertruck isn't as
overpriced as everyone says it is for
everything you get with the price you
pay and you know this is a fun one I
like this one this you know if you if
you search up Twitter or threads it's
not very hard to find a lot of harsh
reactions to the Cyber Tru right it's
it's obviously not a cheap truck it's an
expensive truck but also Al I think the
key with this one is this has got to be
the biggest Delta between what was
promised and what was delivered from
Tesla on paper I've ever seen like it
was a massive overpromise under deliver
moment for them like if you literally go
back and and watch the 4-year-old event
now when they first unveiled the
cybertruck and the specs they had all
the stuff on stage they were saying 0 to
60 and as low as 2.9 seconds up to 500
plus miles of range 14,000lb toone
capacity 3500 lb Max payload capacity
and starting at
$39,900 that seemed killer but today the
new specs are out and the truck that's
actually starting to ship now in 2023 is
0 to 60 in 2.6 seconds which is it's
crazy it's a party trick but then up to
a maximum of 340 Mi of range 11,000 lb
towing capacity 2500 lb payload capacity
and starting at $60,000 going well up
into the six digits so when you compare
what we were promised versus what they
actually delivered Not only was it late
but it just feels like oh this this
thing is crazy overpriced now I would
have been happy with a $30,000 truck
with hundreds of miles of range but now
they're trying to sell us 300 mil for
100 grand like that seems it feels
overpriced but if you compare it to the
exact competition in its segment other
electric pickup trucks that are shipping
right now let's say then it actually
kind of Falls right in line I mean there
isn't really things that we're talking
about here it's F-150 Lightning and
rivan r1t and the Hummer EV pickup truck
that's kind of it and it's right in line
with those so I'm not going to be
counting the Silverado pickup truck
because again they have a promise but
they're not shipping it yet so just for
truck shipping right now either they're
all overpriced or none of them are and
that's not even mentioning any of the
other Innovations related to the
cybertruck that might have taken some
serious R&D whether it's the durability
or the 800 volt architecture or the
steer by wire system that that's first
in any truck we've seen if people care
about that stuff at all I actually think
the real honest take for me anyway is
that if this if this cyber truck came
out this week and didn't have that
announcement event four years ago with
all those over promised specs it would
have been a much more
universally uh interesting car it would
have been very very exciting for a lot
of people in a way that it isn't now
because it had these promises that
weren't met so that's my argument for
not announcing things until you right
about to be ready to ship them
cybertruck isn't overpriced maybe but
probably overhyped good take all right
next one the iPhone Mini would have been
the most popular phone if it had the
battery of the max this one will never
not be funny to me because there there
are always lots of when I ask for hot
takes there's always a lot of like this
gadget was the best of all time versions
of that sentence and seems like the
manyi iPhones just have this like cult
following where everybody loves them now
they only produced this thing for 2
years it was the iPhone 12 mini and the
iPhone 13 mini and they were definitely
great now yes the iPhone 12 mini did
have a tiny battery and some real
battery issues that came with it some of
that was fixed with the 13 mini but it
felt like the second it was announced
and people started reacting to it it had
this like this cult like fan energy
where when it went away you would have
people believing the only reason it went
away is because fitting that amazing
flagship phone and all of that
capability and such a tiny body would be
a battery sacrifice and that's the
reason they didn't keep doing it uh but
they would be wrong I mean they'd be
right about the fact that there is
battery sacrifice but look I love small
phones as much as the next guy I give a
trophy out for the best small phone
every single year but the simple fact of
the matter is people just don't really
buy small phones like when given the
choice it just feels like people think
they're getting more value or they just
prefer the bigger screen whatever it is
but people are just gravitating towards
the bigger version of phones in general
but then on top of all of that just have
a look at the arc for the most popular
iPhones ever like the best sold iPhones
of all time it isn't the newest iPhones
it's the iPhone 6 like we're talking in
their absolute Peak like 200 million
plus units sold of that phone so in a
lineup of several other iPhones like it
was the 12 mini and the iPhone 12 and
the iPhone 12 Pro and the iPhone 12 Pro
Max there was no way even if you had
world class battery and the best
everything and a dozen other exclusive
features like there's no way the mini
would have outsold the bigger phones it
was Noble of Apple to try but it
underperformed so much that it is even
below Apple's expectations and they they
discontinued it and literally replaced
it with the 14 Max the opposite of the
mini iPhone cuz people they want big
phones so yeah all all the takes about
the mini iPhone being a great idea and
being one of the most well-liked phones
ever are true but once you add the it
would have sold a ton part that's that's
when you lose it
bad take okay this one hear me out 4x3
is the best aspect ratio for most video
content so okay yeah that it's clearly a
pretty crazy take but the reason I I
likeed this one and picked it out is
because think about this for a second
back in the day not even five six seven
years ago I was super against vertical
video like if I saw someone taking a
video or a photo like this i' be like
hey just just turn it like that like the
widescreen video the video I'm shooting
right now WI screen the only debate was
like what's better 16 by9 or a little
wider 2x one what's your favorite
everything was horizontal video and that
made so much sense today in
2023 I've had to soften my stance on
that because look the default for most
people now when they go to take a video
is this and then there's Tik Tok and
Instagram reals and YouTube shorts and
even if you're just somebody texting
someone a video from your phone to
someone else they're going to view it on
their phone like this so just people
just take vertical videos by default now
so it's kind of hard to argue vertical
video has its place and so now it feels
like there there has to be some sort of
compromise like how do you just decide
on one ideal video format and I'm not
saying 4x3 is it but what I am saying is
if I could only capture video in one
aspect ratio from now for the the end of
time from now till I die I'd probably
take something closer to squarish so
that I could either crop it horizontally
or vertically to its appropriate medium
does that make sense but I think the
tiebreaker again just to level it back
on Earth here is the future seems like
it it might actually be going back
towards horizontal because of all the VR
headsets all of the spatial video and
all of the horizontal video that works
with VR headsets fun fact iOS 17.2 just
came out and there is a feature in the
video formats where you can start
shooting spatial video on your iPhone I
think it's only the pro iPhones first of
all you can only watch those spatial
videos in the headset the Apple Vision
Pro but the other key is when you go to
shoot that spatial video on your iPhone
it requires you to turn it horizontal
again because it's using the horizontal
distance between those lenses for the
videos it's taking to match the distance
between your eyes and that's why it
gives that spatial video effect so
spatial videos are going to have to be
shot horizontal as as long as camera
orientations look like this so I don't
know 4x3 it's just kind of a a general
square tall wide aspect ratio it doesn't
mean it's the best aspect ratio to shoot
but I'm just saying if I had to shoot
one I don't know it's a it's a bad take
but it's a good take but it's a bad take
all right hot take if Apple came along
and made dedicated gpus it would be over
for everyone else wow so this it's an
interesting thought initially anyway
kind of more just because of the fact
that there are lot of things like if
you're Apple if you're a multi-trillion
dollar tech company like there are lots
of things that people want you to make
that you don't make lots of things
cameras cars printers and so it's pretty
fun to to let our mind wander and wonder
if Apple made some other thing would it
also be this super premium well-made
amazingly performing thing so we did get
the moment where Apple silicon was a
gigantic leap for Apple especially for
the laptops like we went from Intel
chips and discrete gpus to all of it
including the GPU baked into one chip
and those laptops having amazing
performance and great efficiency awesome
does that mean that if Apple made their
own GPU would also be amazing no matter
of fact Apple's just never really been
into gpus in the first place and to this
day they now make an M2 Pro Mac Pro
Tower with a bunch of PCI slots in it
with a tiny tiny tiny list of supported
gpus for very limited functions they
really are not into discret gpus now I
think I think you could argue that if
they made their own discret GPU graphics
card just for their own Mac like the Mac
Pro and you could slap that thing in it
could probably be awesome it would
probably be amazing it could perform
well for whatever functions they've
designed it for but that take said it
would be over for everyone everyone
meaning Nvidia AMD heck even Intel makes
gpus now and they all make those for PCs
and if you think apple is going to come
along and make a great GPU for a PC I
just I I just don't see that happening I
don't think it would be over for them I
think they'd be totally fine so yeah I'm
going to say no shot bad take all right
this is one of the best ones I think it
sparked the most conversation at the
studio a flagship Smartwatch that
doesn't have a 3 plus day battery life
is unacceptable looking at you Apple so
strong take take true but also not
really true I think the obvious rebuttal
is okay you're saying it's unacceptable
but the Apple watch is the most popular
Smartwatch in the it's the most popular
watch in the world and it has a two day
a one and a half day battery life so
clearly people do accept it right but
why do we accept it it's not good like
that's at the very least we have regular
watches have superlong battery lives
months and years obviously but they just
tell the time they don't do much but
there are even SmartWatches out there
that have weeks long battery life months
long battery life I just reviewed the
cmf Smartwatch which is under a 100
bucks 69 bucks and that thing has a five
six 7 Day battery life if you just treat
it like normal and there's the Garmin
SmartWatches that have all these GPS
functions and features and they're
pretty big but they'll last weeks at a
time so then what is the deal it feels
like a 3-day two day or like a one-day
battery life for a smartwatch kind of is
unacceptable right but then I zoomed out
a little bit and actually mentally just
try this for a second second just
replace the word SmartWatch with
smartphone just think about it okay 3day
battery for a smartphone would be pretty
good because a decade ago a one-day
battery life for a phone was nice and
today a full day battery life on your
phone was nice so manufacturers have
clearly they haven't stopped trying to
improve on Battery Technology that
improves all the time but they also have
kept aiming for that one day point over
and over again because it's accepted and
continue to make the phones more
powerful more capable more useful
brighter screens better cameras all that
stuff that takes more power as long as
they can still hit the full one-day
battery life it will be accepted that's
like the industry standard now and I do
feel like with enough volume Apple has
kind of decided the same thing with the
Apple watch if you go back and watch old
presentations with the Apple Watch
series 7 Series 6 Series 5 Series 4
every single time they quote the same
thing 18 hours of battery life and if
there was enough push back and if people
didn't accept 18 hours I think they
would push for 24 full hours 36 full
hours but because people have accepted
it they've started to push on other
things like the always on display a
brighter display a faster processor more
sensors more powerful more unique more
capable as long as they can still hit
that acceptable 18 hours and people
accept it it kind of reminds me of this
beorn tweet
uh about how his Nokia 2310 used to last
a month and now phones these days only
last like one day like how are people
really happy with a one-day battery life
and it's like yeah you're right you're
definitely right about that but also
that was a Nokia
2310 it didn't really do anything like
it had a postage stamp size screen and
probably three or four colors and about
75 pixels that of course that phone
lasted a month if you use a phone today
it's doing a lot more things so if you
want to use a noia 2310 today by all
means go for it and you can still get a
regular watch but if you want a much
larger screen if you want fast
processing a whole bunch of sensors the
Health Data the smart stuff that happens
with an Internet connected computer and
you want it to be small enough to fit on
your wrist well you're going to have to
charge it every night and people have
accepted that bad take all right that's
about all the time I got for this one
but I think this is pretty fun I enjoy
reading your guys' hot takes because
some of them are are crazy hot but some
of them are kind of cold it's just let
me know if you have any more in the
comments below I would love to continue
this series and react to more good
internet Tech hot takes until the next
one catch you guys later
[Music]
peace